start with breaking news on the program
this morning out of the United States
police say several people have died in a
shooting at a Walmart store in Virginia
there have already been 600 mass
shootings in America so far this year
iOS correspondent Martha Kellner is with
us um hi Martha what more do we know
good morning
Kay well this is another day another
mass shooting in America this time it's
going to be the city of Chesapeake in
Virginia on America's East Coast which
will wake up tomorrow morning to learn
of the horrific Bloodshed a Walmart
supermarket we still don't know the
exact number of fatalities but we do
know that there have been multiple
deaths and multiple injuries inside that
Walmart supermarket that you can see
there in the last hour or so the the
local Chesapeake Police have been giving
a press conference the the spokesman
there said that they received the call
around 10 past 10 in the evening and to
tell them of reports of a shooting at
that Supermarket police officers then
entered the store he said that over the
course of 35 to 40 minutes officers
found multiple dead people and injured
people in the store he said they put
rescue and tactical teams together to go
in inside and provide life-saving
measures he also said Mr Kaczynski the
the spokesman the officers were still
searching for victims more than two
hours after they arrived on the scene he
noted that it was a large store which
had lots of hiding spots for Shoppers
who had possibly sought cover during the
shooting people could get scared he said
we want to make sure that everyone is
accounted for I think it's important at
this juncture to to reflect on the
astonishing and horrific level of gun
violence in America I'm sure people will
have heard over the weekend of the
shooting or on Saturday night at an
lgbtq nightclub in Colorado Springs in
Colorado five people were killed in that
incident and 17 wounded since then there
have been five more mass shootings mass
shootings defined as incidents where
four or more people are injured or
killed not including the shooter in
addition this is the 607th mass shooting
in America this year clearly obviously
still some time to go as well gun
violence is steadily increasing in
America year on year and whatever
emerges from this event and I'm sure in
the coming hours and days we'll hear
more about the motive of the shooter
involved we do know that the shooter was
killed as well in this incident whatever
emerges we need to reflect or America
has to reflect once again on what is a
uniquely American problem this
astonishing level of gun violence and
perhaps the laws that maybe allow this
sort of thing to happen on such a
regular basis here yeah so just to recap
for us then if you would please Martha
multiple deaths were hearing at the
moment the gunman uh has also uh been
killed we haven't got exact numbers as
you said yet though
we haven't got exact numbers uh the
police officer who was delivering that
press conference was asked whether it
was more than 10 he said he didn't
believe there had been 10 fatalities but
he did say that they found multiple
people injured including
um someone who appears to have been
killed uh close to the entrance of that
store there's clearly a lot of
conjecture at the moment about the
motives of the gunman whether this was a
disgruntled employee perhaps a
disgruntled customer or whether this was
just simply a random event a random
store uh picked out but it's a couple of
days away from the Thanksgiving holidays
at the moment so clearly uh 10 10 p.m at
night is not a time when that shop would
be as busy as other periods during the
day but this is an incredibly busy
holiday period as they call it here just
two days away from the Thanksgiving
holiday so there will have been a fair
number of people you would imagine
inside that store even though it was
around 45 minutes from closing time and
so I I think we'll we'll hear more I
think from a press conference from the
Chesapeake Police Department in the
coming hours but clearly police still on
the scene there and as until very
recently they were still searching
around that very large Supermarket
looking for people who perhaps had been
trying to find a hiding place to escape
the violence that was unfolding inside
um okay for now thanks very much indeed
thanks a lot so we are waiting to hear
more information from the police in the
area but what we are hearing from
looking at those ladies pictures up to
10 people are dead after a shooting at a
Walmart let's have a look at those
pictures again should we
um let's have a look at those pictures
again should we a Walmart uh shooting up
to 10 people have been killed um we
believe that the gunman is
um also amongst the dead this is at
Chesapeake in Virginia on the east coast
of the United States this story
developing in the last half an hour or
so U.S police saying the gunman is uh
dead as several Shoppers inside that
store around about 10 o'clock at night
um also having lost their lives as a
result of this shooting we'll get more
information and as soon as we do of
course we'll bring it to you here on Sky
News